criminelle pour le dernier de ses
accusés le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale monsieur Chevènement vient
d'annoncer de nouvelles mesures pour
élargir le rôle des parents à l'école
parents et enseignants doivent avoir une
responsabilité partagée mais il faut
fixer clairement les limites du rôle de
chacun la famille peut avoir une action
complémentaire de celle de l'école doit
avoir une action complémentaire
explication de Estelle Guzzi
premièrement responsabilité des parents
les divers conseils ou siègent les
parents devront obligatoirement se tenir
au moins une fois par trimestre dans ces
conseils les parents seront désormais
plus nombreux à égalité avec les
enseignants dans les conseils d'école
par exemple les compétences de ces
conseils sont étendues dorénavant les
parents seront consultés non seulement
sur le fonctionnement matériel et
financier de l'école mais aussi sur la
composition des classes le choix
d'Emmanuel scolaires l'intégration des
enfants handicapés d'autre part
Jean-Pierre Chevènement demande aux
établissements de mieux informer les
familles sur la vie de l'école des
journées portes ouvertes et des
rencontres parents enseignants devront
avoir lieu plusieurs fois dans l'année
au delà des nouveaux programmes publiés
vers la fin du mois de mai des documents
et brochures sur l'orientation et les
diverses filières seront mises à leur
disposition
concernant la composition du conseil de
classe celui ou son prise les décisions
de redoublement ou d'orientation des
élèves aucune modification deux parents
seulement continueront d'y siégé face à
une dizaine d'enseignants ces décisions
sont bien accueillies par la FCPE la
plus importante fédération de parents
d'élèves de son côté la paix deuxième
fédération de parents d'élèves et met
des réserves la politique France